[Musique]
bonsoir vendredi 24 avril bienvenue dans
cette nouvelle édition spéciale sur tv
78 39e jours de confinement en france
dans le département de la crise
sanitaire toujours d'actualité 386
personnes sont mortes dans les hôpitaux
du territoire d'après les chiffres de
santé publique france publié hier huit
décès supplémentaires en 24 heures entre
mercredi et jeudi
dans le même temps le nombre
d'hospitalisations a baissé moins 35
patients 857 personnes sont actuellement
hospitalisées dans les établissements
des yvelines moins de passion également
se trouvaient en réanimation hier
et puis 1247 le chiffre des retours à
domicile dans les yvelines suite à une
amélioration de l'état de santé
quarante jours quasiment après le début
du confinement c'est l'occasion de faire
le point sur la gestion de la pandémie
au niveau départemental entretien avec
le préfet des yvelines réalisé par will
friedrich dépositaires de l'autorité de
l'état dans le département le préfet le
représentant direct de gouvernement nous
sommes en ligne avec jean jacques brot
le préfet des yvelines bonjour monsieur
le préfet bonjour monsieur
nous allons voir comment vous avez
supervisé la situation ces dernières
semaines rappelé également les mesures
en cours et puis forcément évoqué les
premiers éléments les prémices encore
concernant le déconfinement en attendant
c'est bien le confinement qui est
d'actualité
cela fait six semaines les beaux jours
sont bien installés n'est pas question
de penser à se relâcher c'est le message
que vous allez passer encore envers la
veille de ce week end pardon oui bien
sûr nous sommes toujours en arnett
enfants en confinement comme l'ont
rappelé les membres du gouvernement et
les autorités scientifiques et y compris
les bien entendu les hospitaliers les
médecins yvelinois nous sommes en
confinement
les premiers résultats arrivent
incontestablement puisque les hôpitaux
des yvelines
sont moins surchargées les ligues à
quelques lits de réanimation
libre donc ça veut bien exprimé que le
confinement par rapport à cette pandémie
et plus vendables produit des résultats
mais il ne faut pas se relâcher il faut
accepter avec autant de bonne volonté en
tout cas de discipline nécessaire pour
chacun d'entre nous les règles ce
confinement qui peuvent être
effectivement très contraignant pour
certains d'entre nous la communauté
musulmane débute le ramadan ce vendredi
c'est normalement un moment d'échangé de
partage
et tout cela en commun les différents
représentants du culte ont appelé à leur
fidèle à s'adapter cette année à
respecter aussi une fermeture des
mosquées
vous allez éveillé avec les services de
la préfecture oui mais d'abord nous y
avons travaillé en amont précisément
avec le conseil des institutions
musulmanes des yvelines qui a produit il
ya une semaine maintenant une semaine
avant le début du ramadan
aujourd'hui un communiqué très important
qui appelait précisément à une
discipline incivisme spéciaux compatible
avec le bon exercice du mois du ramadan
les autorités compétentes musulmane ont
exprimé à quel point à l'instar d'autres
fidèles d'autres religions yvelinois
comme les juifs les chrétiens récemment
pour les fêtes de pessah et de pâques
l'ont montré eh bien les musulmans selon
heures entendait aussi pratiquer leur
religion y compris le jeûne la prière
la charité est certaine forme de prière
dans le confinement et non pas avec les
formes extérieures qui peuvent être
habituels qui sont d'ailleurs plus
culture culturel cultuel de cette fois
ci en appelant à ne pas s'y adonner donc
je remercie beaucoup naturellement le
conseil d'administration du simi est
d'avoir
appelé les fidèles à cette retenue et
nous entendons être pédagogue comme eux
mais naturellement nous empêcherons par
exemple si ça arrivait des personnes
produisant des petits gâteaux des plats
etc
nous leur interdirons de les vendre
comme ça à la sauvette puisque les
marchés sont interdits et de très rares
exceptions près ne pas envisager
d'exception donc voilà pour une partie
de la population c'est un mois de
ramadhan spéciale qui s'annonce de même
qu'il a été très spéciale singulier et
contraignant pour les protestants pour
les catholiques pour les juifs pour les
orthodoxes tout à fait récemment pour
pâques
vous l'avez évoqué aussi dans votre
réponse la question des démarches et
peut-être fait revenir aussi parce que
vous recevez toujours encore des
demandes de certains qui s'interroge
pourquoi tel marché pourquoi pas un
autre aujourd'hui quelle est la règle
qui s'applique en effet au départ il
faut revenir aux origines le confinement
s'est accompagnée d'une demande
gouvernement du premier ministre et de
tous les ministres donc extrêmement
clair de fermeture de tous les marchés
c'est la règle
la dérogation a pu être envisagé pour ma
part je n'ai comprise de façon suivante
c'est-à-dire en autorisant au bout de
quelques semaines je le reconnais des
marchés et le haut à rouvrir
là où il n'y a pas de possibilités
d'approvisionnement alternatifs jeu g
nous avons permis mes collaborateurs et
moi après étude très particulière dans
certains cas je pense aux halles de
versailles une forme de réouverture mais
extrêmement organisés limites et
contingenté avec une organisation
particulière un sens pour les personnes
qui viennent et pas de contacts entre
les produits et les personnes et
naturellement les règles les gestes
barrières devant être réglée à ceux qui
continuent à insister parfois très
lourdement je pense à tel ou tel élu je
réexplique qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une
contrainte pour le plaisir et qu'il
s'agit bien entendu pas de d'une volonté
de réprimer ou de contraindre telle ou
telle organisation maraîchères et
horticoles
il s'agit simplement avec autant
d'équipés que possible de respecter une
consigne gouvernementale
je vais peut être d'ailleurs sur ce
point ça nous fait un lien avec la
question du ramadan que si dans tel ou
tel marché urbain
demain on nous proposait à mes services
et moi des organisations très réglementé
qui permettent la vente de certains
aliments particulièrement prisé par les
fidèles musulmans pendant le mois de
ramadan si les gestes barrières étaient
bien respectées si la police municipale
et les placiers le vérifier s'il y avait
peut-être certains paquets tout préparé
à l'avancé et bien pourquoi ne pas
organiser des choses dans des halles ou
dans des marchés je reste vert mais il
faut des choses
extraits des organisations très précise
et très original il s'agit pas en milieu
urbain d ouvrir tout simplement je
restais sur cette question du
confinement est ce qu'il est il est
respecté globalement aujourd'hui et pour
étendre un petit peu ma question on le
voit dans certains quartiers c'est assez
compliqué il ya eu alors c'est pas
uniquement liée au confinement mais des
tensions dans certains quartiers avec
les forces de l'ordre qui ont dû
intervenir c'est aussi des choses qui
peuvent interpeller les citoyens les
concitoyens de juillet on est en période
de confinement et on voit ces scènes de
violence avec dans certains quartiers
des affrontements avec la police
sinon je crois monsieur que ce parce que
le confinement a plutôt bien respectée
dans le marteau divine qui le gêne
certaines occupations certains trafics
certaines ventes et certaines habitudes
et donc si on ajoute cette jeune et je
pense particulièrement à ce qui s'est
déjà produit à shanghai où il ya
quelques mois et ce qui s'y est produit
à nouveau très récemment
si on ajoute à cette entrave par le
confinement d'un certain nombre
d'activités illicites et et au noir il
faut bien dire les choses plus la
fatigue qui naît de du temps qui
s'écoule vous avez dit on n'entre qu'en
maintenant la sixième semaine du
confinement
ça a expliqué des prises à partie de la
police assez récurrente il y en a eu
plusieurs soir des suites
oui dans plusieurs quartiers des
yvelines c'est vrai néanmoins nous avons
eu la chance pour l'instant de ne pas
aller aux extrêmes
ce sont des formes de violences urbaines
incontestable qu'ils sont grâce aux 10
heures du mans dont font preuve les
forces de police restée relativement
dans un cadre relativement je ne l'aï
pas dire acceptable mais elles sont par
contre continue peut-être les forces de
l'anp donc employer cet adjectif
relativement encore une fois parce qu'il
soit agréable de voir que ans en prend
la police et parfois aux biens et aux
personnes en balançant des mortiers en
balançant des pierres et autres objets
donc c'est pas convenable c'est pas
supportable et d'ailleurs la procureure
de la république est en net retrait
régulièrement informés et mène la
politique pénale qui est la sienne et
qui est je crois apprécier tous depuis
plusieurs mois donc sachez bien que les
services de police et de gendarmerie
surtout à l'occasion de ce mois de
ramadan qui peut dans certains cas comme
on l'a dit tout à l'heure
impliqué quelques mouvements
complémentaire de population est en tout
cas être pris comme prétexte par goût
malfaisants pour leur entreprise
je répète que les forces de police et de
gendarmerie sont particulièrement
attentives
vigilante seront à la fois pédagogue
mais ferme et que en tout cas mes
collaborateurs et moi même ainsi que les
polices municipale et nationale la
gendarmerie
les maires et nous nous sommes vraiment
sur le qui vive
là on n'est pas encore rodé confinement
on l'a bien compris mais néanmoins il ya
des discussions qui s'engage entre les
différents élus notamment qui sont
sollicités par le gouvernement j'imagine
que vous aussi vous êtes sollicité vous
serez mis à contribution
d'autant que la consigne pour l'instant
ce serait un déconfinement global mais
avec et des discussions sur un plan
territorial avec un binôme préfets
préfets et élus des maires des
communautés des différentes communes
alors effectivement je pense que
l'occasion de cette crise très intense
rappelle un certain nombre d'autorités
ou d'observateurs que à la base quand il
s'agit de sécurité civile s'est en effet
le dialogue qui s'instaure entre le
préfet et chacun des maires qui est la
clef de des secours apportés aux
populations y compris dans le dans la
durée nous avons la chance voyez-vous
dans les yvelines d'avoir un climat de
confiance que je qualifierais de très
exceptionnel entre les autorités
préfectorales le conseil départemental
le conseil régional les maires les
intercommunalités mais c'est surtout les
mères dix ans essentiellement les maires
qui sont concernés avec le soutien du
conseil départemental et aussi du
conseil régional et des parlementaires
il y a une qualité de dialogue entre ses
pouvoirs publics je tiens à le dire à
nouveau publiquement qui fait que en
particulier jusqu'à maintenant dans nos
périodes où il faut bien le dire
il a fallu parfois aider le système
hospitalier
le conforter conforter les ehpad art
elle masque telle organisation renfort
administratifs etc etc
il faut que les yvelinois grâce à vous
monsieur comprenne qu'il y a eu un
dialogue permanent de proximité de
terrain
une explication constant donc nous
n'allons pas re découvrir ce que
semblent parfois redécouvrir les
observateurs plus nationaux c'est à dire
la nécessité
fonder l'action publique sur une
connaissance de terrain
une connaissance des personnes de
proximité je veux aussi mentionné les
associations caritatives les
associations qui représente les
entreprises les chefs d'entreprises eux
mêmes dans ce moment où on envisage le
déconfinement nous sommes en lien
quotidien
que fait l'état par exemple beaucoup de
dialogues par téléphone par mail par
texto par visioconférence par radio
conférence non pas entre nous ça
n'aurait aucun sens mais les uns avec
les autres je veux dire avec les maires
avec le conseil départemental avec le
système hospitalier au cas par cas pour
organiser et en partie parfois avec un
système d pour compenser ce qui n'a pas
toujours être donné donc nous sommes de
ce point de vue extrêmement motivés
ensemble pour en fonction des mots
d'ordre qui seront données quelle date
il y aura-t-il des volontaires pour les
écoles ou pas distribuer ce masque ou
pas etc
je prends l'exemple des tests
actuellement engagés pour voir si dans
les ehpad
certaines personnes ne sont pas atteints
ne sont pas atteints en parlant du virus
et bien ça s'est fait par une
mobilisation que je salue de la rs 78
est tout à fait remarquable avec le
conseil départemental le système
hospitalier en général et le soutien de
l'action de l'état donc vous voyez pour
chaque problème
nous avons réussi une si une mise en
conjugaison de nos personnalités et des
pouvoirs plus et des personnes qui sont
concernées sur la façon dont va
s'articuler le déconfinement pour pour
conclure les choses seront plus précises
on précisé à quel moment à quel moment
vous serez en mesure d'annoncer dans les
yvelines les choses se passeront telle
manière que vous écoutez cette question
est extrêmement comment dire pour être
rester politiquement correct est
acceptable c'est très compliqué de
deviner les choses
on voit en tout cas il ya une chose qui
paraît de plus en plus clair c'est que
les autorités gouvernementales
comprennent qu'il faut revenir aux
méthodes d'antan c'est à dire comme je
viens de le décrire une qualité de
coopération d'anticipation et d'action
la plus des proches du terrain possible
ça c'est une certitude capitaux c'est
une conviction que joueur que j'aie etc
et dont on voit qu'elle commence à se
propager
si j'en crois ce que je lis dans la
presse et ce que j'entends donc je ne
peux pas donner de date du tout il ya
l'horizon qui a été fixé par le
président 11 mai il y à ce qu'on dit le
premier ministre et les autres ministres
dont convoi comptant vers cet horizon de
date
après chaque jour qui passe nous
préparons nous nous préparons pas ce que
je sais et certaines grandes
collectivités le conseil régional mais
en ce moment un conseil départemental où
certaines mairies commandes des masques
nous allons coordonner pour éviter les
doublons je sais que certaines
associations caritatives ont besoin d'
aide alimentaire parce qu'il ya des
désarrois encore accru nous nous
concertons là aussi oui c'est plus une
méthode s'applique dès maintenant la
date
dès qu'on saura vous le diront mais ça
n'a pas ça ne sera pas comme le coup de
départ d'une course à pied ça sera
peut-être un peu plus original merci
beaucoup monsieur le préfet d'avoir été
en ligne en connexion avec nous pour
faire un point sur la situation
aujourd'hui après cette sixième semaine
de de confinement merci avant tu formes
archi merci monsieur le préfet des
yvelines vous l'avez entendu qui a
octroyé des dérogations pour la
réouverture d'une dizaine de marchés
dans les yvelines et ce principalement
dans les communes rurales m et à
versailles aussi les commerces des
halles sur la place du marché notre dame
ont pu rouvrir depuis vendredi dernier
une mesure partielle puisque les clients
ne peuvent pas circuler à l'intérieur
ils récupèrent leurs commandes à
l'extérieur le reportage daury du rosé
de patrick jacques de dixmude d'habitude
le marché notre dame à versailles
ressemble à ça mais aujourd'hui avec la
situation sanitaire les seuls stand
autorisées se trouve devant les
différentes entrées des halles depuis le
17 avril 34 commerce sont présents en
matinée
les gens sont vraiment content vraiment
son sens que ça fait du bien à beaucoup
de gens de ressortir de revoir les
commerçants c'est ça fait partie du
quotidien de chaque versailles et de
venir sur le marché et là de retrouver
un petit peu ça je pense que ça redonne
un petit peu de baume au coeur du moral
avoir du poisson frais à voir le caviste
ça c'est des choses qui sont importantes
on a une satisfaction est également de
retrouver nos commerçants habituels ça
amène voilà une vie important de
quartier d'avoir même réouverte marche
est partiellement pour cette réouverture
la ville a obtenu une dérogation du
préfet des yvelines des tables ont été
disposés pour éviter tout contact avec
les clients les commerçants respectent
également les règles sanitaires
on a tous des masques on a des visières
aussi pour ceux qui travaillent sur
l'extérieur et
on a les gels on a les gants et voilà
moi la sécurité des clients et puis on a
on a mis des fromages sous vide pour que
justement on n'est pas de trop de ce
geste a touché les fromages
en plus de cette réouverture partielle
des halles la municipalité a pris
plusieurs mesures en faveur des
commerçants pour faire face à la crise
lorsque nous sommes propriétaires des
locaux nous ne faisons pas à payer les
loyers aux commerçants pendant la durée
ou une soupe ans d'activité deuxième
mesure c'est que nous faisons pas payer
les droits de terrasses et enfin nous
avons distribué des masques aux
commerçants qui sont ouverts parce que
ce sont des basques dits chirurgicaux
des bases de qualité et ça permet aux
commerçants aux verts de se protéger et
de protéger leur clientèle la commune
estime la perte de recettes lié aux
annulations des loyers des commerçants à
environ 500000 euros
elles ne pourront pas se tenir en raison
des mesures sanitaires les
traditionnelles cérémonies et de
commémoration qui anime la fin du mois
d'avril et le début du mois de mai à
commencer par ce dimanche 26 avril date
de la journée du souvenir des victimes
de la déportation
cette année marquait d'ailleurs le 75e
anniversaire de la libération des camps
de concentration où on était enfermé
plus de 700 mille femmes hommes et
enfants
malgré l'annulation des cérémonies deux
associations celle des déportés internés
et familles de disparus et puis elle les
amis de la fondation pour la mémoire de
la déportation appelle à une
mobilisation dans les yvelines
elles ont demandé notamment aux maires
des communes de déposer tout de même des
fleurs au pied des monuments aux morts
et de publier un message d'hommage sur
leur site internet
les deux associations invitent également
les ivy noah a marqué le coup de manière
symbolique depuis leur domicile pour se
rappeler des victimes écouter rendons
leur hommage et reconnaissance
sortons les photos de nos parents
de nos amis qui ont connu les camps de
la mort les prenons le temps d'écouter
le chant des marais l'hymne des déportés
puis peut-être de fredonner dans notre
solitude dans notre confinement ou en
famille notre marseillaise
je compte sur vous et je vous remercie
cette date vous la connaissez le 11 mai
fin du confinement annoncé par le
président de la république emmanuel
macron alors que la stratégie de
déconfinement se dessine peu à peu une
association basée à saint quentin en
yvelines souhaite apporter son
expérience on en parle avec jérôme andré
bonsoir bonsoir directeurs d'achats
prévention une association nationale de
prévention de santé qui est basée à
trappes on le rappelle alors vous avez
développé un protocole de prévention de
réduction des risques et de dépistage de
masse du coc vite 19 c'est un protocole
et qui s'adresse au public marginalisés
qui n'a pas accès aux soins et vous avez
aussi développer des solutions pour les
entreprises on précise qu à chaque
prévention à la longue expérience sur le
dépistage c'était normal aussi de vous
joindre à cet élan d'apporter votre
expérience
exactement parce que depuis donc 2011
on propose donc jusqu'à seize mille
tests par an au niveau donc de la région
ile-de-france des tests de dépistage
donc du vih et des donc des ist et nous
allons donc au plus près des populations
avec nos unités mobiles d'ailleurs
souvent vous menez d'ailleurs voir pour
relater alors là on le voit avec le
d'apporter donc déteste au plus proche
des populations ces tests nous les avons
nous avons effectivement donc fait
tester donc par des laboratoires dont
pasteur et on attend donc le retour donc
du cnr et il convenait de pouvoir donc
avoir le retour des que du ministère de
la santé
ce qu'on demande c'est effectivement de
pouvoir donc faire les tests et de
pouvoir donc les emmener au plus proche
des gens pour cela on a réalisé donc un
protocole d'entente au col qu'on était
promis à avoir noté en réalité ce
protocole international avec des
signataires de renom un nouveau
va donc nous permettre et permettre à
d'autres associatif de pouvoir donc
faire des tests commis 19
les tests qui sont effectivement donc
sur le corps à des virus et les français
donc les attendent
parce que plus que jamais les français
doit le savoir bon leur statut
sérologique avec un protocole vous
l'avez dit qu'il sera destiné à des
publics auprès desquels vous vous
intervenez régulièrement il ya aussi des
solutions pour les entreprises qui ont
été imaginés par hachette prévention
exactement on s'est associés donc à deux
cabinets donc de renault en management
et en communication donc de crise
l'idée c'est d'aller au plus que au plus
proche des salariés de l'entreprise
parce que ce sont eux qui sont les
véritables acteurs de la relance
l'économie qui est donc à portée des
tests mais aussi apporter des nouvelles
solutions de management va permettre à
ces entreprises de pouvoir se relancer
dans la continuité les de manière
complètement durable il était nécessaire
effectivement d'apporter des solutions
efficaces tant sur la santé que sur le
management est donc aujourd'hui on a on
se rencontre on a un vrai besoin de
pouvoir donc relancé à la fois les
entreprises c'est pour ça qu'on a fait
des propositions très concrètes à
valérie pécresse notamment que j'ai
rencontrés hier puisque valérie pécresse
a fait un don de deux mille masques à
h/f prévention justement pour lancer
donc nos initiatives et puis on a fait
une proposition effectivement aussi au
classement et puis à jean michel
fourgous puisque hommes comme vous le
savez on est des enfants donc de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et donc on a
aussi à coeur d'apporter à la fois des
solutions pour toutes les entreprises
donc à travers la france puisque le
kabyle les cabinets peuvent avoir cette
compétence là et puis d'apporter bien
sûr notre savoir faire sur 50 ans lui
lit alors jean michel foucault juge le
précise pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
présidente saint-quentin-en-yvelines
othman castro qui est aussi
vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines également
conseiller régional juste sur le
protocole dont les dans les grandes
lignes à quoi à quoi ressemble-t-il ce
protocole eh bien vous avez déjà filmé
des tests de dépistage du vih
avec hf prévention on en réalise 16
milles et ils ont quasiment la même
forme que les tests donc on utilise
habituellement c'est à dire qu'en deux
trois gouttes de sang on va pouvoir
donner donc avec une certitude
quasi aussi fiable qu en laboratoire on
va pouvoir dire aux gens s'ils ont été
mis en contact avec le co vie de 19 et
si l'on développé ou non les anticorps
donc le protocole fait aussi en sorte
donc de dire comment vont se dérouler
donc ces tests et vont il va pouvoir
dont internet de le mettre très
rapidement dans des unités mobiles un
peu partout en france
alors vous avez été reçu par le
président de la région ile-de-france
valérie pécresse est ce que vous
demandez aujourd'hui à être reçu par
d'autres pouvoirs publics peut être au
niveau de l'état aussi exactement
puisque à chaque prévention comme vous
le savez nous sommes opérateurs avant
tout donc des agences régionales de
santé et donc du ministère de la santé
le travaillons également avec d'autres
ministères mais donc et qui a très
normal qu'il y ait effectivement des
cellules de crise qui se sont à noter
même si nous connaissons les gens des
cellules de crise et qu'on leur fait des
recommandations
on a effectivement ces cellules de crise
en contact mais on trouverait normal que
dans le cadre de la démocratie en santé
des structures associatives telles que
la nôtre ou même des citoyens tout court
soit auditionné parce qu'aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas faire effectivement donc une
campagne de stop and go c'est à dire on
confine les gens et puis on va les
laisser donc derrière ce re contaminée
pour ensuite dire qu'on va probablement
reconfirmer si on n'a pas les masques si
on n'a pas les gants si on n'a pas de
traitement et a fortiori s'il n'ya pas
donc deux tests on va effectivement donc
on demande à être reçue effectivement
par les pouvoirs publics
même si nous sommes en lien constant
avec les agences régionales de santé
d'ile-de-france qui sont un travail
extraordinaire ainsi que le ministère de
la santé on demande effectivement à ce
que nos solutions soit porté au plus
haut
on a fait des recommandations également
au ministère dont les armées qui nous a
sollicités dans le cadre d'un appel à
projet est maintenant on demande
effectivement à ce que nos solutions
soient mises en place
les français veulent connaître leur
statut sérologique les entreprises
veulent être leur relance et c'est pour
ça qu'à chaque prévention propose à la
fois une solution concrète de
dépistables de de dépistage aussi fiable
qu en laboratoire et des packs
entreprise pour pouvoir donc relancer et
redynamiser donc le pays avec des
solutions qui aident à qui allie à la
fois le management de crise
mais aussi le domaine de la santé d'où
le fait qu'à chef prévention va
maintenant faire de la prévention
y compris en entreprise voilà pour ce
protocole imaginé par votre association
germandrée hf prévention dont vous êtes
le directeur merci d'avoir été avec nous
est le retour du club de la presse ce
week-end sur tv 60,18 les journalistes
des médias locaux des yvelines se
réunissent pour revenir sur l'actualité
du mois dans le territoire il sera bien
sûr question dans ce numéro de la crise
sanitaire et de la gestion et des
conséquences dans les yvelines
participation de toutes les nouvelles de
marmites fm et invités de ce numéro
pierre bédier le président du
département des yvelines s'est exprimé
notamment sur les conditions du
déconfinement voici un extrait pour moi
la règle la plus intelligente
j'aurais de faire ce que d'autres pays
ont fait et ce que nous nous sommes
capables de faire si nous voulons c'est
permettre toutes les activités je dis
bien tout à condition que lorsqu'on
rentre dans un lieu où il ya plusieurs
personnes entraîne systématiquement
qu'on ne fasse pas systématiquement la
température s'il y a
à travers cette prise de température
suspicion d'infection dont on ne connaît
pas la nature à ce moment là
immédiatement la personne est dirigé
vers un laboratoire point tests
sérologiques pour savoir si elle a
simplement eu une les pep une une rage
de dents ou le comique 19 si elle a le
qi de 19
naturellement elle reste chez elle elle
est donc confiné le temps ces trois
semaines le temps de la quarantaine
c'est une demie quarantaine dans et
naturellement elle est suivie on utilise
et là il faut qu'on soit raisonnable
on utilise ces données téléphoniques
pour savoir avec qui elle avec des
contacts pour faire une enquête
épidémiologique rapide et ainsi on peut
reprendre une vie normale
le club de la presse des yvelines c'est
à retrouver à partir de ce week-end sur
tv 78 ou en replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile et
puis en mode sport avant de vous laisser
on l'a appris cet après-midi la 43e
édition du paris versailles et reporté
à l'automne 2021 la classique des
courses pédestres devait se tenir le 27
septembre prochain décision motivée par
les risques sanitaires et
l'impossibilité de garantir le respect
des gestes-barrières sur cet événement
toutes les inscriptions d'ores et déjà
effectuée pour le rendez-vous seront
valables pour 2021
les personnes qui le souhaitent peuvent
également demander un remboursement
chaque année la course attire environ
25000 personnes sur ce 16 km entre paris
et la cité royale
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale merci de votre fidélité
restez chez vous c'est très important et
très bon week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]